[Music]
crawling through underground pipes
[Music]
racing to catch a mushroom and saving
Princess Peach all things you did in the
Mushroom Kingdom you might think you
know everything about your favorite
high-pitched turtle splashing Italian
plumber but you have no idea let's start
from the beginning the very beginning
guess when Nintendo was founded in the
19th century 1889 to be exact they
started out as a playing cards
manufacturer and as years pass expanded
their line of products going from toys
to instant rice and even taxi services
fast forward to the 1970s the company is
in dire financial straits and is looking
to reinvent itself with the Golden Age
of video games in full swing
Nintendo saw an opportunity to join the
fray so they entrusted a young artist to
lead their initiative a man that would
ultimately change video games forever
this is Shigeru Miyamoto the
world-famous creator of the world famous
character module and this is how Mario
got his look
the SWAT team a demonic aura no Hammond
a the mahadji dot polka dot polka oh hi
oh one name is Damita ha city way all at
the National Post other minor vocalist
allocate a tentacle area nearest Okamoto
but that was quite a challenge in 8-bit
furthermore my dog Coco cologne was
gushing on there MA I know let's get
there
and one thing led to another having your
heels killed they communicate because
that's not the boss council the
secretary or from 90-meter who sees you
al Qaeda little Mario no sighs honestly
yeah now our character needed
well a name it's your autonomic upload a
video game you'll endure mr. video that
video game was Donkey Kong good career
aha so no chinko no kanojo took off her
hat their sorrow a cockerel manic manic
and Anissa and that's silly Hiro had a
signature move
about tomorrow night still right there
mom boom boom boom mr. video became jump
man a carpenter climbing ladders on a
construction site but he needed a more
relatable name Sakai you know stole
Acharya Simona aku Donkey Kong war
American yoga risotto so no don't go
more an Ohana is Reutimann even hasta la
daddy
to a warehouse in seattle to be precise
and what happened there a patent on oka
a no soap una loca so con soap no soap
no honey no Rosanna Mario sent you here
I stole his underpants that landlord was
Mario Segale egg and he looked like this
with a mustache neat they don't know
their weight so that guy inspired
Mario's name look boy you know I own
that day so we had a funny idea we
wanted to look for Mario Segale a that
elusive landlord
turns out he still lives in the Seattle
area and he's still in real estate
in fact he's quite a mogul his name is
even on a street sign we tried to call
him to ask about Mario but he didn't
want to comment on the matter what
happened in that warehouse stays in that
warehouse after Donkey Kong our hero was
ready to be a star on his own so
Miyamoto set out to design him his own
world a pompom pampas of the job meet
Okajima Loretta Hawaii toboggan on a
mini Gaddafi kabocha determine if that
stone that a dog Mario was jumping over
pipes so naturally he became a plumber
Danka here you could do you know whole
superhero the American Pig on it instead
Mario is kind of a chubby blue collar
hero unique modem or not connected a
nice dough now she's gone home also
we're still in Baltimore oh but yes
could be in players got to enjoy even
more Mario with his doppelganger
satchel Mario budahas do not exceed is
GTO total evidence net more study
Mario Naruto CID most of the Madonna or
not like Mario his name has quite a
story my Panther Guinea Mario not see me
you may like that in the character lays
it up and it was meant to be losing
wanna do is eat in a while even though I
meet a redundant sale although the Mario
Brothers have a lot in common
Mario he remain the truth
and ultimately he's more than a video
game character
odo son Roman I do still care a
cataleptic
state of trampled winter festival - -
never do we see him pretty much
everywhere but we'll never look at the
Nintendo mascot the same way Mario is a
legend and so is his creator
Minamoto matter who knows when elegy
Runa councilman or suitable causal
architect on
[Music]
you